يدخل اللاعبون الى كاس العالم باملي تمثيل
مشرف في بلادهم يخوضون غمار المباريات بكل
قوه الى ان تخونهم اجسادهم واصاباتهم تاتي
الاصابه مثل الكابوس لجميع اللاعبين في
كره القدم تضربهم في وقت ذروه المباريات
بينما يكون الحلم في اوجه لاكمال البطوله
العالميه وتحقيقها الى امكان تتنوع اصابات
اللاعبين بين ردود والتواءات مفاصل
والكسور والاجهاد العضلي والتمزق
والغضاريف والرباط الصليبي بينما قد تكون
الاصابه اكثر خطوره حين يتعلق الامر
بارتجاج المخ الشديد او الصدمات التي قد
تؤدي احيانا لفقدان الذاكره
وكسر في الجمجمه
العديد من اللاعبين حرمتهم الاصابه من
اللاعب في كاس العالم او اقبال البطوله
بعد بدايتهم فيها حيث حرمه الاصابه لاعبي
المنتخب السعودي ياسر الشهراني وسلمان
الفرج من اكمال المونديال بعد المباراه
الاولى الملحميه مع الارجنتين كذلك حرم
المنتخب البرازيلي من مجهودات لاعبي نيمار
دا سيلفا وكابريال كاسيوس والك بعد
اصابتهم خلال دور المجموعات المنتخب
الارجنتيني خسران مجهودات لاعبه ديماريا
في مباراه دور 16 امام استراليا سبب
الاصابه وفقد لاعبه جيوفاني لوسيو بعد
بدايه المونديال اما المنتخب الفرنسي كان
اكبر الخاسرين في المونديال حيث خسر كريم
بنزيما قبل ايام من الانطلاق الحدث
العالمي وكان قبلها ده خسر مجهودات لعبه
بونج بوبا ونغولو كانتي فيما خسر منتخب
السنغال نجمه الاول ساديو ماني من البطوله
بعد اصابه عضليه تعرض لها قبل كاس العالم
بايام
[موسيقى]
الصحفي الرياضي محمد حامد محمد يسعد صباحك
معنا من جديد في الاستديو صباح الخير
الاصابات يا كابوس المستطيل الاخضر
كاس العالم يقام في هذا التوقيت ماذا حدث
الانديه الاوروبيه الكبيره الانديه
الدوريات في مختلفه انحاء العالم كانت
بالفعل بدات هذه الانديه لا تريد ان تخسر
موسمها فكم وفي نفس الوقت تم الاتفاق على
اقامه كاس العالم في هذا التوقيت فتم ضغط
المباريات بعد ان كان همم
الامر الشائع او الامر الطبيعي مرتين في
الاسبوع اصبح ثلاث مباريات في الاسبوع لكل
نادي وبالتالي ضغط المباراه التي تاثير
كبير جدا على مساله الاصابات مساله اخرى
ان التجمع
لكاس العالم هذه المره تم قبل اسبوع واحد
فقط من انطلاق البطوله الشائع قبل
البطولات الكبرى امم اوروبا كاس عالم
تحديدا كاس عالم ان يكون التجمع قبلها
بشهر فبالتالي لما بيجي للمدرب لاعب مصاب
بيكون عنده بيكون عنده وقت كافي انه يعالج
الاصابه هذه المره شعورنا بكابوس الاصابات
بسبب بسبب كل هذه المتغيرات
بحسب الدراسات الطبيه تمثل 80% من
الاصابات واخطر الاصابات اصابات القدم
وشوفنا النوع من الاصابات مع نيمار اللي
كانت اصابته كثير يعني هزت الجمهور حدثنا
اكثر
لعبه كره القدم هي ليست لعبه عنيفه ولكن
ما يحدث انه احيانا فارق سرعه ما بين
اللاعبين يتسبب في دخول لاعب بالخطا في
مناطق صعبه جدا على صقل اللاعب
نعم نعم يعني احنا مش عايزين نفترض مساله
ال- ال- التعمد موجود بكل تاكيد ولكن
نسبته قليله جدا في كره القدم الوتر اللي
بيفصل ما بين همم
القدم والساق هذه اخطر الاصابات
ويعاني منها غالبا اللاعب المهاري لاعب
المهاري اللي هو بيمسك الكوره كثير بيحتفظ
بالكوره كثير فبالتالي فرص التدخل عليه
بعنف بتزيد ذكرت نيمار تحديدا خلينا نيمار
عامل ظاهره في المونديال نيمار لاعب مهاري
جدا ولكنه اسف يعني مستفز جدا للخصم يعني
ايه مستفز لما المدافع يجد امامه لاعب
مهاري بيهين كرويا خلينا نقول احيانا
يتعمد يتدخل عليه بحاله من العنف واحيانا
بيضع قدمه في مكان حساس في قدم اللعب
وبالتالي يتعرض للاصابه نقطه اخرى عن
نيمار وما يزعلوش مني عشاق البرازيل نيمار
ليس منضبط كثيرا خارج الملعب مساله
الانضباط خارج الملعب اساسي في لياقه
اللاعب وفي مساله تعرضه من عدم تعرضه
للاصابه نقطه مهمه جدا ميسي كريستيانو
انتم بتبصوا لقوا المحارب وبتبصوا الاشياء
ومتغيرات كثير انظروا اللي فكره كم مره
يصاب صح ميسي رونالدو صلاح عدد كبير من
الاساطير الاستمراريه وعدم التعرض للاصابه
هو جزء من اسطوره اللاعب وبالتالي موضوع
الاصابات موضوع مهم جدا في كره القدم في
حال اصيب اللاعب عدنان فتره زمنيه قليله
قصيره بين المباريات نتحدث عن فرصه العلاج
والنقاء حسب الاصابه حسب الاصابه
والمناسبه في متغير نفسي كمان اللاعب
الفايبر اللي عنده رغبه في العوده بيعود
اسرع من غيره وهذه المساله معروفه في عالم
كره القدم ولكن اذا كانت الاصابه في
الركبه على الاقل من ثلاث الى ست شهور
الاصابات العضليه ايضا صعبه جدا من ثلاث
اسابيع الى شهر وخاصه في العضله الاماميه
والعضله الخلفيه هناك نوعيه من الاصابات
صعبه جدا ولكن اصعبها على الاطلاق يعني
ربنا يحفظ الجميع اصطدام الراس بالراس هذه
مشكله خطيره جدا في كره القدم
الصحي لكل اللاعبين قبل اي
اذا بنتكلم في ليفل كاس العالم ولا بشكل
عام لا لا دي مساله ليفل عالي جدا واكيد
في اجهزه الجهاز الفني من ضمن اعضائه طبعا
المسؤولين عن اللياقه البدنيه المسؤولين
عن الجانب الطبي وجانب كمان اهم الاستشفاء
ماذا بعد المباراه يعني مساله الاستشفاء
اساسيه في عوده اللاعب سريعا وعودته بافضل
صوره ممكنه موضوع التسخين والاحماء وهذه
الاشياء طبعا مساء العلميه جدا ومقدره جدا
لعيبه اللعيبه وخاصه في هذا الليفل العالي
جدا وبالتالي هي من الاشياء الاساسيه اللي
بتحمل اللاعب من الاصابه
معنا في الاستوديو الصحفي الرياضي محمد
حامد منورنا شكرا محمد